alright Andres why be happy when you
could be ecstatic that's a great
question I mean I do think that we have
a lot of cultural hang-ups about like
very positive states of consciousness
you can definitely see that in the
context of you know we kind of like talk
around the edges when it comes to things
such as you know the pleasure of orgasm
or even like heightened states of
consciousness like like meditation we
don't really have currently the ability
to culturally integrate the fact that
there's this fantastic states of
consciousness and possibly that we might
be able to experience them sustainably
in some sense we got as a society we get
off and signaling in every misery we
show up like to others just how
committed we are to a cause by showing
just how distressed we are about it but
I think like we we may very well be on
the brink of a paradigm shift when it
comes to really embracing and not
feeling guilty about being in ecstatic
ecstatic states of consciousness
sustainable ecstatic states of
consciousness and culturally integrated
been culturally integrated whoa